si la casa blanca acaba de declarar
emergencia de salud pública el brote de
viruela del mono esto permitirá a las
agencias nacionales acceder a las ayudas
federales y poder gestionar mucho mejor
la distribución y el acceso a las
vacunas ya los medicamentos para frenar
este virus esta declaración llega
después de que se encontrara el primer
caso a mediados de mayo y a día de hoy
estamos ya por encima de los 6 mil 600
contagios llega también esta declaración
después de que estados como illinois
nueva york o california ya lo hubieran
hecho la semana pasada ante la situación
a la que se estaban enfrentando y por
miedo a quedarse sin suficientes vacunas
contra la viruela del mono de hecho ese
estado de emergencia que allí se declaró
entró en vigor este mismo lunes y eso
como decía pues le permite acceder a más
fondos federales y acceder también a más
vacunas contra la viruela del mono
porque esa es ahora la gran preocupación
que no hay vacunas suficientes muchos
expertos sanitarios le recriminan a la
administración de baire que tardó mucho
en reaccionar tardó al menos tres
semanas en pedir las vacunas en liberar
y pedir al por mayor las vacunas que
tiene en un centro en dinamarca para que
se distribuyeran en el país pero parece
que la casa blanca se está tomando muy
en serio esta viruela del mono de hecho
este martes giovanna designó un
coordinador nacional para que se
encargue de gestionar la respuesta ante
este brote y han dicho que se
distribuirán más de 750 mil dosis en
todo el país ahora mismo hay contagios
en los 48 estados excepto en dos en
montana y en wyoming que no han
reportado ningún caso por el momento